يحدث هذا بشكل لا يمكن إنكاره وأعتقد أن معظم
النمو ليس بالأمر الجذري عندما
أقول إنه مدعوم بالكثير من البيانات على مدى
السنوات القادمة لن يأتي
من الأسواق التقليدية مثل أوروبا
وأمريكا الشمالية، بل سيأتي من  الشرق الأوسط،
إنه يأتي بالفعل
من الشرق الأوسط، أعتقد أن
هناك انعدامًا متزايدًا للأمن في الغرب،
وأعتقد أنه في بعض الأحيان يكون رد الفعل في
الغرب أحيانًا في الولايات المتحدة أه
يبكون أن أمنهم القومي
يتعرض للتهديد عندما يكون من
الواضح تمامًا ذلك  يتم ابتكارها
في قطاع تلو الآخر من قبل الشركات الصينية في بعض الحالات،
وأحيانًا
شركات من أماكن أخرى في العالم، حيث
تجد الولايات المتحدة وأوروبا صعوبة
عندما تبدأ الشركات من أماكن أخرى في
العالم في التنافس معها
في الشرق الأوسط.  إن تواجد الشرق في قطر
يجلب قمة الويب هنا وهو أمر
مثير للغاية لأنني أعتقد أن الأمر لا
يتعلق بإنشاء حدث إقليمي
لجلب رواد الأعمال إلى المستثمرين من
المنطقة معًا، بل يتعلق بجلب
بقية العالم
إلى قطر إلى الشرق الأوسط وإظهار
أن هذا  هو
سوق مهم بشكل لا يصدق، هناك
قدر هائل من الأحداث يحدث ولكن على المستوى الجيوسياسي ولكن
أيضًا على المستوى الاقتصادي، ولا
يمكنك أن تكون هنا، يجب أن تكون هنا، ويجب أن
تكون هنا وأنت تلعب بنفس القواعد التي يتبعها
أي شخص آخر،
مهمة قمة الويب هي عدم وضعها  على خشبة
المسرح،
الوضع الراهن اليوم، الرؤساء التنفيذيون
للشركات الكبرى، كما
تعلمون، يذهب سكان المحيط الأطلسي إلى
قمة الويب لاكتشاف المستقبل،
وهو المكان الذي سيولد فيه المستقبل
عندما تجمع 70 ألف شخص معًا
كثيرًا  منهم رواد الأعمال الذين لا
يقبلون بـ "لا" كإجابة، إنه نوع من
الجو المحموم والمثير بشكل لا يصدق أه والمجنون [
الموسيقى]
نأمل أن تخلق مع مرور الوقت واحدة من
أهم التجمعات العالمية في
الشرق الأوسط، إنها ليست ليست
إقليمية  سنجلب
الحاضرين من جميع أنحاء
العالم من نيجيريا من اليابان من البرازيل
من كندا، وستكون
فرصة لهم للقاء
أفضل الشركات وأفضل الشركات الناشئة وأفضل
الشركات سريعة النمو
ولقطر لإظهار  في العالم أن هناك
قدرًا لا يصدق من الأحداث في
ريادة الأعمال
[الموسيقى]
على مدار 50 عامًا، كانت التكنولوجيا والتقدم
التكنولوجي، سواء أكان ذلك في أشباه الموصلات
أو أجهزة الكمبيوتر نفسها، مدفوعًا إلى حد
كبير بالولايات المتحدة
وخاصة وادي السيليكون بدرجة أقل
بوسطن أعتقد في المستقبل
ستهيمن الصين على وجه الخصوص على
التكنولوجيا بطريقة
يكاد يكون من الصعب تقديرها في هذه
المرحلة
[موسيقى]
كما تعلم أعتقد أن الذكاء الاصطناعي أمر حقيقي للغاية،
وأعتقد أنه مع كل موجة من التكنولوجيا الجديدة المثيرة
أو التطور في
مجال معين من التكنولوجيا
في بعض الأحيان يمكن أن يخرج الضجيج عن السيطرة، لكنني
لا أعتقد أننا على وشك
فقدان جميع وظائفنا وأن
البطالة ستكون
نتيجة نظامية للذكاء الاصطناعي. منذ حوالي خمس سنوات،
كان هناك الكثير من الضجيج حول الروبوتات
وذاك  الروبوتات سيارات الأجرة الروبوتية كل شيء سنقوم
باستبدال الوظائف ولكن في
كثير من الأحيان يكون الأمر متروكًا لنا كمجتمع
لاختيار ما نرغب في تطبيقه أو
الاتجاه الذي نرغب في دفع هذه
التقنيات إليه،
شكرًا لك